[Musica]
siamo a Bruxelles nell'ottobre del 1927
a quello che Albert Einstein Aveva
soprannominato il convegno delle streghe
non vi prendete paura non è niente di
che è solo un importantissimo congresso
scientifico in cui le streghe erano 29
tra le persone più importanti della
storia della scienza che avrebbero
cambiato il corso delle cose nella
fisica quantistica
pensate che ben 17 di loro erano o
sarebbero diventati i premi Nobel quindi
una vera e propria concentrazione di
quelli che chiameremo dei geni
tra loro c'era anche lei Marie Curie una
chimica geniale con ben due premi Nobel
e una storia così avvincente e a tratti
anche problematiche alle spalle
se non ti avessi detto che c'era lei
forse non ve la saresti nemmeno
immaginata perché oltre al fatto che
questa foto è in bianco e nero ed è un
po' vecchia lei non era particolarmente
femminile quindi si mimetizza molto bene
all'interno di questo gruppo di soli
uomini e non escludo che questo effetto
fosse effettivamente voluto
oltre a essere l'unica donna in questa
foto per molto tempo è stata anche Forse
l'unica donna essere un po' conosciuta
nella scienza perché di tutte le altre
che hanno contribuito a fare scoperte
invenzioni non si sa molto oggi
Ovviamente iniziamo a leggere qualcosa
di loro sui libri ma per molto tempo di
queste ragazze chiamiamole così come
Sofia covalescaia Comedy Lamar come Ada
Lovelace o Cecilia Payne non l'abbiamo
conosciuto molto
Eppure hanno contribuito a fare scoperte
invenzioni importantissime che tutt'oggi
quotidianamente utilizziamo però si sa
quali erano tempi un po' diversi con una
mentalità un po' retrograda C'erano
tantissimi problemi da risolvere
figuriamoci se le donne che a volte non
potevano neanche a studiare erano così
importanti da valorizzare Oggi abbiamo
una situazione molto ma molto diversa
pensate che addirittura a bordo di
un'astronave l'equipaggio crew for che è
andato nello spazio proprio nel 2022 su
quattro membri a ben due donne e una di
queste è stata appena nominata
comandante della stazione spaziale
internazionale
Immagino che di Samantha cristoforetti
abbiate sentite parlare e quella
bassettina mora con i capelli sparati
quella che va nello spazio e lascia a
casa per ben sei mesi i due poveri figli
abbandonati con il marito Mentre se ne
va a fare esperimenti per non si sa
quale motivo
Ovviamente sì è anche un astronauta con
una laurea in ingegneria meccanica
un'altra laurea in scienze aeronautiche
con un sacco di cose interessanti da
raccontare e tante esperienze alle
spalle Ma perché è concentrarci sul suo
essere
astronauta e fare domande o su
Informazioni tecniche quando possiamo
concentrarci sul suo essere donna e
soprattutto mamma
Eppure mi risulta che un suo collega
Luca Parmitano anche lui astronauta
molto famoso e nessuno abbia mai chiesto
come avrebbe gestito i figli durante le
missioni spaziali e soprattutto se
avesse dei figli
le domande che vengono Poste a
scienziati e scienziate non sono domande
casuali nascono da curiosità delle
persone che a loro volta nascono da
stereotipi per giudizi che ci portiamo
dietro da millenni con la nostra cultura
sulla scienza e su anche chi ne fa parte
E a proposito di stereotipi Immagino che
se adesso vi chiedessi di immaginare e
di disegnare qualcuno che si occupa di
scienza La maggior parte di voi
prenderebbe come modello lui
uomo con un camice bianco con i capelli
bianchi e sparati tipico scienziato
pazzo che magari sei in un laboratorio
di chimica a guardare una provetta
fumante Sì ho preso
in pensate che questo esperimento che si
chiama proprio Joe a Science che viene
fatto in tutto il mondo proprio per
studiare la percezione Gli scienziati e
scienziati da parte dei bambini ci dà un
grossissimo vantaggio la parola
Scientist in inglese non si obbliga a
pensare a un uomo o una donna
anche io vengo da un laboratorio di
chimica l'avevate pensate Immagino però
mi sono sentita dire un sacco di volte
che non avevo l'aspetto da chimica non
sembrava una scienziata E pensate che
per alcuni Questo era addirittura un
complimento
mi sono chiesto un sacco di volte allora
che cosa Questo volesse dire come
incideva sulla percezione del mio lavoro
su quello dei miei colleghi o delle mie
colleghe e soprattutto mi sono chiesta
Ma che aspetto deve avere uno scienziato
uno scienziato e soprattutto Ma perché
ci interessa Che aspetto hanno uno
scienziato uno scienziato a quanto pare
per molti Questo è un indizio importante
perché parla di autorevolezza di
competenza e anche di affidabilità
soprattutto nella scienza
dopo tutto anche i film e le serie TV
sono abituato un po' questo stereotipo
degli scienziati nerd poco attraenti con
dei serissimi problemi a socializzare
Forse è anche per quello che ci fanno un
po' tenerezze che ci piacciono così
tanto
perché ci interessa questo aspetto
perché se pensiamo alla prima foto che
abbiamo visto e pensiamo ad oggi sono
cambiate tantissime cose molte più
persone studiano scienza molte più donne
hanno accesso all'istruzione e
soprattutto ai corsi di studio
scientifici la scienza stessa ha fatto
passi da gigante e l'innovazione
praticamente esplosa negli ultimi
decenni
quello che non è cambiato così tanto e
così velocemente però è l'accesso equo
al progresso scientifico soprattutto
quando parliamo di rappresentanza
femminile
pensate che oggi il 54% delle ragazze ci
dice che ama la scienza è interessata
Però pensa che sia poco adatta ad una
donna e questo è un vero peccato
ma non solo se prendiamo tutte le
persone che a livello globale si
occupano di ricerca scientifica vediamo
che il 30% di loro è donna e non è un
numero bassissimo Ma si trovano tutte a
ricoprire ruoli che sono alla base di
questa piramide e man mano che saliamo
verso l'apice ne troviamo sempre di meno
eppure i dati le statistiche ci dicono
che le donne media si laureano in tempi
più brevi con voti più alti e spesso
hanno livelli di formazione più elevati
rispetto ai loro compagni ma non
riescono ancora ad arrivare in massa in
quei luoghi dove è possibile decidere
dove è possibile tracciare le rotte
della Ricerca Scientifica della Scienza
e allora ci troviamo davanti a una
situazione un po' particolare che
potremmo descrivere con una metafora
Ovvero quella di un tubo che perde un
lunghissimo tubo che però invece di
perdere gocce di acqua perde persone e
perde competenze man mano che andiamo
dall'inizio alla fine e più persone
competenza perde più occasioni perdiamo
anche noi come società
i campi Sam che sono quelli di scienze
tecnologia ingegneria matematica sono
quelli che storicamente hanno visto
sempre meno donne sia nei percorsi di
studio che anche nei percorsi di
carriera e questo avviene per tanti
motivi ma noi ovviamente Sappiamo
benissimo che in parte è dovuto al fatto
che beh Noi donne non siamo brave in
matematica No in generale Diciamo che
non siamo proprio tagliate per la
scienza perché è un po' troppo difficile
e competitiva e poi in generale non ci
interessano le materie tecniche perché
si sa è roba da uomini poi c'è un altro
fatto noi ci dobbiamo occupare di
famiglia quindi non abbiamo tempo per
sviluppare una carriera scientifica
ambiziosa e parlando di ambizione visto
che solitamente ci arrendiamo subito Non
siamo proprio tagliate per questo tipo
di lavoro È vero no
questi sono stereotipi e pregiudizi che
ci siamo sentiti dire molto spesso in
maniera più o meno diretta in maniera
più o meno inconscia e anche spesso da
persone che dovrebbero spronarci a fare
del nostro meglio essere ambiziose ora
Chiariamo una cosa gli stereotipi sono
un qualcosa che nel nostro cervello
utilizziamo tutti i giorni sono
meccanismi normali che il nostro
cervello utilizza per catalogare le
informazioni per capire come prendere
decisioni velocemente quindi della
maggior parte dei casi ci semplificano
la vita per altre volte ce la complicano
soprattutto quando ci impediscono di
esprimere appieno il nostro potenziale
le nostre competenze le nostre risorse e
soprattutto quando ci vengono affibbiate
caratteristiche Sulla base del fatto che
siamo uomini o donne e che non hanno
nulla a che vedere con chi siamo e con
chi vogliamo diventare soprattutto
Allora io oggi vorrei chiedere il vostro
contributo per uscire da questo circolo
vizioso per spezzare le catene di questi
stereotipi per fare in modo che non ci
sentiamo più legati da essi e
soprattutto per raccontare una scienza
che sia più equa e accessibile perché
una scienza più è così accessibile vuol
dire anche un'innovazione più
sostenibile per la società per
l'economia e anche per l'ambiente vuol
dire avere una medicina che è in grado
di concepire delle cure più sicure
efficaci per tutte e per tutti vuol dire
avere delle città a misura di cittadino
e di cittadina vuol dire avere anche
degli algoritmi degli intelligenza
artificiale che oggi utilizziamo sempre
di più che sappiano prendere delle
decisioni in modo da rispettare le
esigenze di ognuno e ognuna di noi
per una scienza di questo tipo ci vuole
una nuova narrazione ci vogliono nuove
domande Ci vuole un nuovo approccio a
partire dal fatto per esempio che a fare
scienza sono persone che fanno scienza
prima ancora di diventare scienziati e
scienziate persone che hanno
caratteristiche vite interessi uniche e
non generalizzabili se prendessimo una
lente guardassimo la categoria di
Scienziati e scienziate vedremo che è
molto ma molto meno omogenea di quello
che pensiamo
e questo è importante perché sono
proprio queste persone che ci devono
ispirare diventare dei modelli di ruolo
dei modelli di ispirazione per tutti e
tutte per ognuno ognuno di noi ed è
ormai dimostrato che se noi raccontiamo
Ogni aspetto degli scienziati e
scienziati raccontiamo i Momenti di
gloria e di sconforto raccontiamo il
work in progress ovvero tutto il
percorso di crescita avremo dei modelli
molto più raggiungibili di quelli magari
più fenomenali e di successo ma che
magari ci Sembrano davvero
irraggiungibili
e sono sempre queste persone che insieme
giorno dopo giorno e passo dopo passo
collaborano per far avanzare la scienza
ormai sappiamo che la scienza non si
basa sulle spalle di singole persone ma
su Team che collaborano insieme e anche
i primi Nobel ci hanno abituato ad una
visione in cui si responsabilizzano
singole persone ma in realtà la scoperta
quella che vince e il fatto che si può
collaborare insieme quindi dobbiamo
raccontare una scienza che sia meno
individuale più collettiva e più
collaborativa
anche a partire dalle domande che
facciamo loro perché se vogliamo
raggiungere le pari opportunità
nell'accesso al mondo scientifico
dobbiamo rendere eque anche le nostre
curiosità le nostre domande quindi che
ci interessa Per esempio il percorso di
studio che sta facendo uno scienziato la
scoperta che ha appena fatto la tecnica
che ha utilizzato Quanti figli ha E come
li gestirà dobbiamo fare queste domande
a tutti e a tutte Anche perché
altrimenti ci perdiamo una parte
interessantissima del racconto che è
circa del 50%
infine Vorrei tanto che rispondere a
questa domanda fosse occasione di
parlare di opportunità e non di problemi
il fallimento rappresenta uno dei temi
più importanti quando si parla di
divario tra uomini e donne perché se da
un uomo Ci aspettiamo che fallisca lo
consideriamo un valore aggiunto quando
si parla di fallimento tra le donne si
tratta questo tema con molto più timore
invece il fallimento dovrebbe essere un
diritto
insegnato gestito e soprattutto
raccontato soprattutto quando si parla
di scienza quindi invece di pensare a
cosa rispondere quando ci chiediamo e se
puoi fallisci cambiamo la domanda
chiediamoci Quando è stata l'ultima
volta che abbiamo fallito E che cosa
abbiamo imparato perché sarà scontato
che avremo imparato qualcosa e sarà
scontato che avremo fallito
io Parlo per esperienza perché il camice
che ho indosso di fallimenti ne ha visti
parecchi ha visto anche qualche successo
ma soprattutto ha visto crescere
cambiamenti ed evoluzioni io ritengo
essere questi successi più importanti è
un camice che mi ha tenuto compagnia per
tanti anni ed è stato un valido Compagno
di avventura Però penso che non mi serva
più per dimostrare Chi sono che cosa ho
imparato chi sono diventata e
soprattutto che sono una scienziata
quindi adesso lo vorrei togliere
e simbolicamente vorrei togliere insieme
a lui tutti gli stereotipi e i
pregiudizi di cui abbiamo vestito la
scienza fino a oggi
e sapete cos'altro dovremmo fare
dovremmo smetterla di farci limitare dai
limiti dell'immaginazione di qualcun
altro e anche dai nostri Grazie
[Applauso]